لا أستطيع أن أتجاهل أنني لا أستطيع أن أتحدث عن الفرح في
هذه اللحظة بالذات عندما كل ما أراه وأسمعه
وأشمه يتألم عندما
يحترق بلدي وشعبي على الأرض
عندما يكون كل حلم هو طلقات الرصاص
والجنود عندما تكون كل مكالمة هاتفية هي القنبلة
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
لا أعرف ماذا أقول لأنني
متعب جدًا ، لقد سئمت جدًا من الاضطرار إلى
إثبات نفسي وجودي
وإنسانيتي من الاضطرار إلى عرض
كل ذكرياتي المؤلمة للعالم
ليهتم بها.
هل يجب أن أخبركم بقصص
الأهرامات وأساطير المعابد ، هل يجب أن
أريكم صحاري الذهب
والغابات والمزارع السماوية
تثير الإثارة على الأسود والجمال
والكثبان الرملية ، ألا يكفي
أننا بشر وننزف؟  بنفس
الدماء لماذا لسنا كافيين لماذا لم نكن كافيين أبدًا ، إنه أمر
مفجع ما يحدث في
السودان
على الرغم من وقف إطلاق النار المتتالي
وهم يواصلون اتخاذ هذه الترتيبات ،
نرى كيف يستمر تعرض المدنيين
لخطر الموت والإصابة الجسيم.
إرث أجدادي
وآمال الأجيال القادمة من
الشابات المسلمات السود من
الشعب السوداني مع رسالة مفادها أننا لن
نستسلم بأننا لن نستسلم بأننا لن
نخسر أننا
سنواصل الكفاح الذي سنعيش عليه.
نعيش ونزدهر
إن شاء الله شكرا لك